the US Supreme Court is two months into
its current term and in the coming
months we'll take up potential landmark
cases including one that could determine
how we draw up congressional districts
two other cases before the court could
also have major implications one
involves government access to our
cellphone records the other looks at
whether business owners can refuse to
accommodate same-sex couples due to
religious objections to break it all
down we are joined by CBS News justice
reporter Paula Reid Paula good morning
good morning let's start first with the
cellphone records what's on top in terms
of that case so this case comes amid
this larger national conversation about
how much access law enforcement can get
to our digital records there is no doubt
there is more information about me on
this cell phone than there is in my
entire home so in this case law
enforcement was investigating a string
of armed robberies and as part of this
without a warrant they were able to get
cell phone location data that's this one
your cell phone pings to a tower and for
the suspects who got all the way to the
Supreme Court he was convicted partially
on this data they had almost 13,000
points of location data for him and he
sued saying they should have been able
to get this without a warrant hmm so
this case involves the Fourth Amendment
which was literally written centuries
ago but now is in Bly being applied to
new technology how difficult is it to
interpret this well there's a
long-standing principle that once you
give your information or your data over
to a third party that it's fair game for
law enforcement but again let's look at
our phones think of how much information
yeah you almost have to hand over to a
third party if you want a cellphone now
there are some laws on the books that
speak to this but they're from the mid
80s I think think about what technology
was like at that time they really just
don't apply so the justices know that
they're in a spot here they need to
clarify this so law enforcement can do
their job but they absolutely seemed
open in oral argument there perhaps
curtailing this a little bit mmm another
case that's heard next week involves a
Colorado cake shop could have very
significant implications for same-sex
couples tell us about it absolutely the
only thing we're stressful I guess the
new law enforcement and Technology right
now is is wedding planning and
right now in this case you had a
Christian business owner Jack Phillips
says he is a Christian businessman and
he employs a lot of his Christian
principles in his business for example
he's not open on Sundays he has refused
to make cakes that involve alcohol or
for Halloween or that celebrate divorce
so of course a same-sex couple came to
his bake shop and wanted a cake and he
refused they sued arguing that
Colorado's anti-discrimination laws does
not allow do not allow him to refuse to
bake this cake but he has actually
challenged that on First Amendment
grounds and that's what's so interesting
is he's not arguing about religious
freedom or anything I thought he's
saying the state cannot compel me to
create a message that I disagree with
what are the implications here
potentially for businesses well the
sweeping implications there are some
concerns that now anyone who's in a
quote unquote arch artistic business so
that would be in terms of marriage
florists or hair salons tailors perhaps
calligraphers as well that they could
now refuse to provide services and while
some people say oh look this is just a
pretextual argument it's a pretty good
one and there was there was a hunt for
awhile after the Supreme Court decided
that same-sex marriage is marriage there
was a hunt for cases that could get back
up to the Supreme Court to really try to
carve out some exceptions just like what
they're seeking here interesting well
not at the Supreme Court level Paula
you've been reporting on a Department of
Justice investigation that involves
prominent Ivy League university and
affirmative action policies that's right
I mean this could potentially go back to
the Supreme Court and I think that's
part of the idea the President himself
has said perhaps it is time for
affirmative action to be revisited do we
still need it so under that umbrella the
Justice Department is currently
investigating Harvard University for
possibly discriminating against Asian
students in its affirmative action
policies now Harvard has declined to
provide the Justice Department with
everything it wants in this
investigation just late last night I
spoke with Harvard they said that they
have complied they've given the Justice
Department everything they want but so
far we've seen in this case that
compliance they're having a little
trouble agreeing on what exactly that is
what exactly that means
so we'll see on Monday whether or not
the Justice Department sues them or if
the two sides will continue to proceed
with this investigation but it is
unprecedented it's unusual for the
Justice Department to investigate
systemic discrimination at a university
and this also happens amid a time when
the Justice Department's Civil Rights
Division is really rolling back and this
is political appointees at the Justice
Department that are leading this
investigation right yes it's a the Civil
Rights Division at the Justice
Department and we tried to ask the
Attorney General about this earlier this
week and as I'm sure you've seen on CBS
this morning and evening news those
questions were shut down which is
something I've never seen before at a
press conference the intrepid polar and
thanks for as always Paula